we're all here just excited to talk to
each other the thing i i noticed about
the cameras is that because they're on
this side that you always ha you kind of
have a great job no matter what yeah
because you're looking left you're
looking right
we gotta
megan has for the listener at home she
has dropped a liquidy thing
it was
she has shattered a glass bottle but
she's willing to to work through it this
is meg's worst nightmare yeah yeah yeah
you guys this is our center
are we rolling
oh this is all good stuff
did you want to talk a little bit about
the brook no
i see a little red dot on the cameras
yeah there's cameras now we're now
filming those podcasts don't cut that
don't
[Music]
uh rob i have a question for you um
did you come straight from the set of ap
bio and are you playing jack now because
you're dressed in my wardrobe on the
show
what show is this ap
is it still on
are you still doing that
yeah
oh i didn't really have that cool
i thought you were done i thought you
said we're gonna do three and then that
was it uh no well we did four
love that charlie doesn't even know how
many seasons we did well you know
seasons are
they all blend together charlie produces
the show that we're doing then i don't
know that he knows how many seasons
we've done that's not true
that's not true i know and i have
critiques but you won't listen to them
so good luck
good luck
that's the kind of thing though that's
the kind of thing that'll get you fired
up
yeah right yeah that kind of telling me
that i that i don't care about the thing
that i'm producing yeah that gets under
my skin yeah
yeah yeah i don't like it i don't like
it why yeah because you're attempting to
discredit my uh connection to the show
not really i'm i'm i'm just giving you
i'm just giving you [ __ ] no no
there's something under it there's
something there no there really isn't
yeah i no i it really isn't there really
isn't no i i i don't know
it's just something you're sensitive to
for whatever the same way i'm joking
about not knowing glenn's show even
though i actually put this on this
morning and thought oh this is the way
that
i'm not if you said i didn't know your
show
um
that's fine because i'd have nothing to
do with your show
right i minimally have something to do
with your show i was i created the show
i have as much to do these shows you
want me to do
which seems like not too much which i
appreciate yeah
that was the original deal we wrote it
together that was good
and then you kids are on your own that's
fine fine you're doing great thank you i
love the show thank you
he's offering his services but he
doesn't want you to take it up on it you
are him up honestly i'm well aware of
him
there's been a couple of times where i'm
like oh do you want to come in the room
and then he's like yeah yeah we can i'd
love that we could work it out but then
i'm like he doesn't really want to he's
saying that he does which is really nice
golf yeah and he should be able to he's
earned that
no i i i do i like
the couple times you've been like hey
you want to work on an episode i've been
psyched to do that yeah
and i would come do some acting or
whatever that'd be a lot of fun yeah so
look i take the show the thing is that
nobody's listening to that exactly
nobody cares about ap bio guys nobody
cares about mythic questions they care
about it's always sunny in philadelphia
i don't know about that you guys seen
that beatles documentary
yeah it's [ __ ] great yes don't get me
started you don't what's what's what's
your deal
what's your don't get me this is amazing
this is gonna be good to get me in
trouble [ __ ] glenn hates the beatles
oh you get that [ __ ] out of here no
that's not totally accurate what i hate
is that the beatles seem to be uh given
the credit for having like i don't know
invented music or something like
can we just
stop it with the beatles that's that's
my thing right yeah
there was so
much musical innovation happening at the
time that the beatles were out okay
were they part of that yeah they were a
huge part of it maybe even the biggest
part of it
but did they invent rock and roll did
they did they did was anyone else from
the 60s
worthy
of uh
of the kind of attention that the
beatles get it's just like
can we just shut the [ __ ] up about the
beatles god damn it
you're not annoying the beatles you're
annoyed at people's love of the beatles
i'm annoyed at the the the the amount of
times that the be like i'm annoyed at
like
the amount of [ __ ] out there there is to
celebrate the beatles but not to
celebrate all the other bands that were
doing cool [ __ ] at the time that's what
annoys me okay um yes the documentary is
amazing yeah it's great because you
really just see like the moment where
paul picks up the guitar and he's trying
to figure out songs like chugga chugga
chugga choose jojo wasn't much
you see the creative process that like
really laid bare this is a stupid thing
to
compare it to but
it really
made me appreciate our process and what
we get to do and just
you know the times that we've just been
in a room stuck and then you're just
bouncing ideas and you're and seeing the
creative process seeing how something
comes from seemingly nowhere
and then goes through someone and then
gets shaped by someone else is exciting
to watch so whether you like the beatles
or not yeah
whether you like the beatles
charlie feels and i agree that we are
the beatles
of basic cable late night well no no no
no i would say that we're i would say
that we're the kinks right we were like
we were around the kings we were yeah
because they because they made music for
like forever the beatles made music for
like six years okay like six years and
then we're like we're out yeah you know
what i mean and the kids just kept going
and going and going it's like pretty
cool and people listening to them
yeah exactly
did they have some hit songs yeah they
had a bunch of hit songs they had great
hit songs by the way i'm a big kings fan
i love the kings
um but they never hit like the
mainstream not well i mean they did they
did there's a couple of things but
people don't people recognize the songs
but if you ask them who are the kinks
they would have no idea yes and i can't
name the kinks i can i can name the
do you think you are then if definitely
ball
yeah
okay well who which which kink are you
jerry garcia yeah see there oh yeah
let's see that's the problem with the
kinks
yeah
yes then what's that weird if you're
paul which beetle am i which people do
you think i am
i think you're a little bit of paul i
think you're paul too i think you're
paul
[Music]
if you guys call me ringo i swear to
[ __ ] i swear to god
oh george harrison you know jordan
maybe john i mean you're definitely
harrison like you know like uh
yeah yeah
john lennon
he was about to give me john lennon well
in terms of the relationships that he
was he was
you got a little john lennon too you got
a little john lennon i don't know but
you got that george thing where you
could you could go and write an amazing
song on your own and then you don't get
the credit for that but then you're like
you can do it man but you see like paul
is like a maniac like constantly like
pushing things forward and saying guys
like let's go let's go let's go
that's me but i feel like that's you too
yeah it is that's true
yeah i don't know okay so we're we're
all a little bit of paul mccartney a
little bit of john lennon
george harrison yeah and nobody's ringo
ringo's finger was [ __ ] great by the
way yeah we're all three egomaniacs
right you think we're the words
and the beatles broke up in when they
were 26. yeah but they looked like they
were in their 40s yeah they did they
have baby faces but they also look
ancient the way people used to that's
interesting i i do agree with you though
charlie i i've always and i've talked to
you guys about this like i've always
felt like our show
like i've always felt a thought of us
more as a almost more as a band than uh
than people making a tv show because
you know there's there's not many people
out there that uh and they're you know
there's a handful for sure but like
there's
very few people are actually the writers
on the show who are also the actors like
who make the show write the show produce
the show and act on the show you know
what i mean in the same way the band
writes their music and then goes and
performs it well that was the
interesting thing to me too is like how
sort of generous they are with each
other in that where
you know you sort of hear these stories
about oh they're fighting and stuff but
not really you know it's like paul would
have an idea and they would like hear it
out and then john would want to do thing
or george got a little testy about
something but then they
you know they're like all right let's do
it your way and yeah oh so i am george
you said he got testy that i'd see i
don't know their but that sounds like
that sounds like everyone
are we going to talk about sunny are we
going to talk about how we're the
beatles i just
i just pulled up my notes i think those
conversations the hair more interesting
but yes we can segue into sonic yeah and
listen then we can segue back into the
beatles i'm i'm down with that or we can
talk about other bands uh you know that
aren't the [ __ ] this episode did not
make me feel like we were the beatles no
no no it doesn't didn't hold up for me
well there were moments yes there's a
lot of really really funny moments so
there are like some high high highs and
then there's a couple kind of clunky
lows i feel like there were some things
though that we established in this
episode um
like i believe this is the first
reference am i wrong about this so to
charlie killing rats
oh he comes into the beginning he's like
he's like i just killed about how many
other rats in the basement and i'm like
good work yeah you know uh and that
that's i think that was the first
reference to you being the guy who's
like you know killing rats this show is
so old
and we we did that so long ago that
there were still many many places bars
that allowed smoking yeah yes yeah yeah
that picked up on that right now and
that change where they were making there
was a debate there was this episode
about a debate about whether or not you
could smoke inside and yes that's hard
to still smoke inside some places like
yeah casinos and whatnot yeah yeah yeah
right right right but like your average
pub
in the us nowhere in the united states
now is that gone everywhere now i think
it is because i i i think it's a
starting it's a state-by-state thing so
i have to think that maybe there's some
states that can you know but you can
also like
make that uh a rule of whatever
establishment you own i believe yeah i
believe like regardless yeah yeah of
course that'd be crazy
because you remember that where that rat
thing was coming from
no because i had so many rats in my
house oh yeah you were getting in my
house real rats yes and you had a
raft yeah yeah
yeah and the red terry was just like
sleeping and the rat would like run over
its head
um
yeah you had to bat i remember very
distinctly you have it about i do
remember that but you you had a good
system and then i i've adopted that
system and i just used it last weekend
when i when my cat had a mouse that was
like still alive and he was like playing
with it because yeah
he's a savage yeah and i use the the way
that you you taught me how to kill it
oh i don't remember i was pretty
ruthless in the day and i i it haunts me
yeah
you could still hear that scream
put it in the bag yeah you put it in the
bag no it's a good way to go look uh let
me tell you something quick okay you put
it in a bag and you smash the phone
there are humane traps you can get
because it's fast you can catch these
things and you can bring them way out to
the woods or whatever but during the
pandemic i had two mice get in my house
and they were they were like [ __ ]
everywhere and wreaking havoc
and i caught these [ __ ] in a glue
trap and i was like i can't do i can't
do it i can't kill the mouse so i got
olive oil i got the thing out of the
trap right i got all the glue out of its
fur and i released in my yard and i was
like i felt better about that i'm like
all right that's i'm sorry little mouse
and then and then a hawk just
immediately yeah yeah well i'll tell you
what the the [ __ ] came back
they came back and they gotta die now
they gotta i gotta die shut up everyone
shut up guys
this episode is brought to you by peta
uh giving animals a chance all over the
world and uh making you feel bad about
your choices regarding animals hey i'm
peter and i bash rats
peter ratbasher oh peter peter that's
awesome that's it yeah so then these
[ __ ] come back in the house and i get
a humane trap i'm not going to catch
them humane trap i catch them i drive
them all the way to i read that you have
to take them like 20 miles from your
house otherwise they so i find a nice
trash dumpster in griffith park that i'm
like this is a good place for you to
live yeah and i let them out there oh
good for you hey you know you know there
are actually this is crazy somebody told
me that they were having a rat problem
at their house was a friend of ours and
uh they said that
they found a rat
sanctuary
okay so there are places
you can get the thing that i find so
funny about so what they do is they take
in
rats right like in the way that you
would that other organizations would
maybe take in a stray cat or stray dog
they take in stray rats
right from people who have trapped them
and don't want to kill them i guess
and then they try to you know they have
a certain email list or whatever they
contact people who would like to adopt
these rats
and the thing that i think is so funny
about that is i can almost guarantee you
that 99 of the people that are adopting
them are feeding them to other animals
yeah yeah you know what i'm saying
like nobody's like there aren't enough
people out there that are like i would
like to have a rat as a pet no they're
like feeding it to their
construction
yeah you're you're reinstituting the
natural order of things so that's not a
bad thing yeah and in my case i'm
talking about my cat is a legit savage
and will yeah bring the mice in and
torture it yeah
yeah
now i have a stray cat too to keep all
manner of small creatures from my home
and so he's the mouse is already dying
and the cat's like i'm gonna keep this
thing alive so i can [ __ ] with it and so
that's why i bashed them do you think if
they could uh the organization peta
would
like
have a go at your cat and come come down
on your cat and make your cat feel bad
about what it does to these mice you
know what i'm saying no
it's torturing animal an animal yeah but
it's another animal who doesn't have the
brain capacity to understand what it's
just doing what a cat does i think it
knows exactly what it's doing because
the thing is is like the spirit of a
witch is living inside that cat you know
that right yeah you know that's how it
works which is yeah they die they're bot
they shed their bodies and then they and
then they go into cats and then you
rescue them and they torture animals so
you know really it'd be peta you know
sort of uh that's really punishing a
witch yeah yeah yeah yeah
by the way i don't i don't mean to put
down all witches i i think there are
probably a lot of witches out there that
are doing good things i just don't know
what they are
well you got to educate yourself well
not
first of all there are no witches out
there don't go calling yourself a witch
until you get your ass on a broom and
fly across the sky right [ __ ] yeah
you know like yeah yeah
you could be into wit [ __ ] right that's
cool you could be witchy you could be
into which culture yeah you could
identify as a witch which in these days
is about as close as you can get uh is
it still appropriate to call a male
witch a warlock or is that a separate
thing no no no oh i think you're right i
think it is i think it's a warlock so a
witch is very specifically only women i
bel yeah that's that's right well you
could be when you speak for all women is
that uh is that accurate
you could be a witch doctor
in which case you could be a man or a
woman you know because doctors are men
and women why did you give me that look
men and women and all non
all people can be doctors so which
doctor you know you wouldn't call it a
warlock doctor although that's pretty
cool yeah yeah
we're laughter
oh what a doctor we just invented we
just created a new show guys
warlocked her you know what i mean he's
like he's an i'm traveling medicine man
you know that's the person medicine yeah
sorry medicine well no we said
specifically that the
war if you add war to it it's male 1
[Music]
and let me consult my notes guys all
right
so a shout out to lucas papalia
he's so good in the episode he's great
yeah he's still keeping that guy uh
minimally but i i should i miss him i
should reach out to him the guy with the
long hair who's protesting
yeah was an actor pal of mine from new
york yeah and a very talented guy it was
always fun to still lived in new york at
the time so it was easy for him to make
the trip into uh philly right it was it
was always fun to hire our friends
because
you know uh first of all a lot of our
friends are super talented and but it's
also that you there's that dynamic that
you guys have and that scene that like
you just wouldn't get necessarily with a
with a
regular guest yeah with a stranger guest
star like you know what i mean like he's
he's really playing with you because he
knows your sense of humor he knows your
style yeah and he knows he can play yeah
bringing it back to the warlock
conversation charlie may dabble in the
dark arts because i believe charlie day
or charlie charlie charlie day why
didn't they do that because
you're the only person consistently
through season through season that
doesn't change the way you look exactly
the same have you been you look very
different glenn caitlin looks very
different i look different i think danny
looks different that's just that's just
genetics well see he might not be
dabbling himself but like he like i
could have a good witch on my side who's
going to stop
their witchy spell because they heard me
denounce witches i take it back thank
you for your witness
and thank you for this fountain of youth
that um yeah yeah absolutely i don't
know i don't agree i look much younger
in those episodes well looking at you
now yeah but but in my mind you you you
seem i mean but yeah dude that was
16 years ago
you don't look dramatically different no
you don't look dramatically different
it's it's kind of weird i haven't done
dramatic things to myself you know like
i haven't like uh gained a dramatic
amount of weight star
silly for years yeah
i can't i don't have the discipline um
yeah yeah gotta have discipline to
starve yourself guys it's not easy
it hurts yeah yeah
because your body's dying yeah exactly
oh yeah can you okay so charlie tell
tell everybody the story um behind the
uh rock flag and the eagle song that
became so iconic i feel like it's a riff
that like hornsby and i had where
mourinho and i would joke about truck
commercials and that they you know they
at that time i don't know if they're
still doing this it seemed like they
were just
pumping out the most uh
they were stereotypical american things
it was like eagles and rocks and it was
just like you know yeah flags flags
flags flying everywhere they're still
doing that they're still doing that yeah
yeah yeah yeah absolutely yeah the i
think the f-150 is the uh still the um
highest selling vehicle in the united
states of america i think
megan you want to verify that megan
megan i believe that's right or maybe
it's the high selling truck but i think
it's the high i think it's the it is the
highest selling vehicle yeah so we used
to joke around about like car
commercials and you know like i got
rocks and flags and eagles you know drop
a big truck on a kicks mass whatever so
that i think it was just coming from
there just like grabbing that riff in my
head but also you know what mary
elizabeth had a really funny one too
she used to joke
that they would take it as far as like
jesus carrying the cross and then all of
a sudden like a truck comes up and he
like throws the cross in the back of the
truck to take himself up the hills like
jesus transformed
so credit credit to mary elizabeth for
that that's a that's pretty great but
that was not scripted
at all was what was script there was not
a song to be sung he just started i
think it was just like don't try it on
me or something yeah
i remember but i remember talking about
this with him at the time i don't
remember if it was when we were writing
the script or when we were doing the
scene
and him telling because i remember him
telling us back in the day yeah
and hornsby used to joke about
yeah about truck commercials but the
song i think was just you just came up
no the song yeah i just spit out on the
spot i do feel like the chorus the rock
flag and eagle that was from the thing
yeah it ended with that but then that
was the thing that you guys used to do
but you added a whole thing before it
like i love that you're laughing through
the whole thing yeah but i can see yeah
yeah and i remember they were laughing
too which is why we don't cut which is
why we don't cut to them well no we
don't cut to us
that's why like i i was watching the
episode last night and and jill was with
me and she she it's like one of her the
fav her favorite moments in the entire
show
uh and uh she loves it like we sing it
all the time at our house but um
uh
it's great because you look at caitlyn
and she just
reacts
like a real you know what i mean just
like it's like looking at him like what
what is he doing you know what i mean i
guaran i know for a fact that you and i
were just laughing yeah that's why you
don't cut you don't cut down
you basically wait until he leaves and
then it cuts back to our real that's
right that's right because we were
laughing through the whole thing yeah
that's funny and we would have ruined it
uh i also remember i don't think you
would be able to get through that now i
think you you would have cracked
yourself up even more now than you would
back then i think no i think it's
switched i think in the beginning
i think i was much more
quick to like think something's funny
that i was doing and now it's it's
[ __ ] you man and you too like i when
you do a funny thing i'm dead i'm like i
can't it kills you i can't look at you
the uh the scene i remember that was
really hard to get through was was you
talking about
explaining that oh yeah what girl's
going wild is yeah yeah and we got like
my god you're so straight in this
episode yeah oh i'm so stressed so
straight you're a different character
yeah i'm a completely different person
pretty much yeah yeah i i that's
actually i was thinking that too when i
was watching them like oh this is i feel
like this is the first time i ever did
that sort of like dennis creepy
you know creepy dennis thing of like uh
you know guys because it's very it's
very reminiscent of what we do later
in the episode where i say like don't
you want to live in another man's skin
you know what i mean there was something
very funny to me about like a very low
voice like very intense you know yeah
and i remember thinking that at the time
like oh that's funny like if if it gets
very
quiet yeah and i think i remember
charlie kept saying like get closer get
closer get closer and the closer we
would get them it's like almost like the
way i talk on the microphone yeah and
your lips were like right up against my
face yeah i couldn't stop laughing i
noticed you better without the pop card
the pop card was luring you in yeah yeah
without pop popcorn you seem to be fine
yeah
well yeah that's i don't know if they
know but i will say the pop guard i feel
like does a better job at preventing the
pops because i can put
pop the [ __ ] out of this thing yeah we
might have to go back to the pop guards
that might be a juilliard thing i've
gotten so good at i got so good at
articulating
you know what i mean that like my peas
are particularly my plosives are
particularly intense
three vehicles in the us are trucks yeah
the top one is the ford f series yeah
what'd i say yeah yeah what percentage
of person
how good did that make you feel you were
very happy about that you were so
excited to be right about that well you
know it's like you when you you know
it's like one of those things where like
i know i'm a smart guy and then when i
say something smart and it proves to the
world how smart i am then it's like oh
now not only do i know that i'm really
really smart now everyone knows right
right so of course it feels good it's
satisfying yeah for sure for sure i like
when i get something right i'm very
happy with it
always uh if you get super happy about
getting something right though probably
what it really is is that you're super
insecure about it
i'm wrong yeah yes
um
can we stop down for a second to talk
about trucks
why
did that percentage of people need
trucks how many people need well
a lot of people need trucks
are working and need that truck that's
what i'm saying you're not hauling lawn
equipment around and lumber and all that
kind of stuff but i think you know the
the average american is just is like
needs to be able to haul [ __ ] around
because they can't average americans
the pers the majority of people are
hauling needs
well
and they're super cost effective they
are cost effective i like trucks i kind
of want one
absolutely
right
yeah that's right you had a toyota
toyota prius
but you had a pickup truck yeah that was
a little bit un-american of you though
you want to talk about that
toyota it was that yeah that was that
was made in the us of a did you color
out the side so it just said yo on the
back no oh you didn't do that oh i
should have that would have been cool
it would have been funny for you to do
it knowing how stupid that is but to do
it just to annoy your friends yeah you
know i mean that would have been the
kind of thing that seems like you're a
sensible my brother still drives that
truck he still has that yes it still
does yeah they love 20.
yeah they make things last they make a
good trip ever great forever great trip
and and you really do use it a lot more
often than you than you think well
listen i mean you know if you can't if
if you can't hire a mover because you
know you don't want to have to pay the
money then you know you get your friends
together and you you throw stuff in your
trucks
and you haul it from here to there you
know but his dad hauled kids in the back
of his truck yeah you know like we would
go to baseball games and stuff in the
back of the house before they had that
was before the the dual cab truck was
more prevalent right so the only time
that we had to like get down is like
when we were going over the bridge and
going off the island and in rhode island
and then be like all right get down and
go to the tall booth because i don't
want to get pinched going like 50 on the
highway with like six kids in the
background
yeah it was awesome it's totally it was
the best way to write super fun yeah
super fun super dangerous and super
super fun yeah that's what we did the
same thing safety kills the fun man it
does kills all the fun oh god uh there's
a moment uh in the episode that always
made me laugh that's the there's a lot
of it that's uh in the um there's
outtakes of it in the bloopers um but
it's
i always find it so funny the concept of
like dee asking you where is your breath
oh yeah and you're thinking it's an and
you think it's in your mouth
and it's
the reason it's funny to me is because
like
it there it's plausible that somebody
would be like where's my where's my
breath well i feel it in my mouth like
that's what well technically it is in
your mouth also you know right right and
if you're if you're looking for it where
would you find it yeah and then and then
in the bloopers
in the bloopers uh you know you
misunderstood you're like she's like no
no it's in your diaphragm and you're
like what no the diaphragm that's the
and then you like make a gesture like to
keep the babies out or whatever you have
a little rubber like uh yeah yeah yamaka
that goes in the
in the ass
in the outtakes uh you refer you you say
that like yeah it goes and it goes in
the monkey hole oh yeah oh my god that's
bright we got that why didn't we put
that on the episode
i don't know maybe we thought it was too
far too far i don't know i don't know
maybe maybe because like you guys were
laughing i didn't maybe we laughed
through it probably but that was but
that was one of the first instances in
which somebody was making caitlyn break
consistently oh yeah she's not she's
like tough not to crack she's tough yeah
that's one of the first scenes i
actually remember doing just me and
caitlyn although i know there are other
ones from the like when we go to see the
pop-pop yes in the season before but for
whatever reason that one sticks out to
me is like it wasn't a pairing that
happened all that often yeah and we were
riffing and it was and it was funny yeah
yeah yeah yeah i love that i love that
scene i love that i love everything a
lot and i always enjoy it those episodes
are always really funny to me yeah
so
big theme in this episode obviously is
uh is patriotism
right uh-huh do you guys consider
yourselves uh
patriots are you proud of this country
yeah yeah absolutely i love this country
tell me why so do i good i'm glad we
established that now if you were to
fight for this country and join one of
the armed forces
uh which armed force which branch of the
military do you think you would be
inclined to join wow
i think i want to be a marine
you want to be on the ground you want to
get yeah yeah just to have gone through
that and say yeah i'm a marine
don't [ __ ] with me
right cool so you wouldn't do it to
fight for your country you'd do it
because on the other side of it you'd be
like
considered a tough guy for both yeah
yeah yeah absolutely the perception you
like the perception of being a marine no
i would like the reality of being marine
you would yeah my buddy carl's a marine
how to get rescued and uh you know if
you come across a bear you're like
[ __ ] i'm a marine and then you get
killed anyway because yeah that doesn't
matter
unless you have a gun yeah but your
attitude is different right you're not
screaming uh you're not screaming and
running away you're screaming and
running at the bear and the bear's going
oh no that doesn't work that doesn't
work i know you've been taught that but
i'm gonna maul you now and then you die
but either way you die a hero because
you were a marine unless you win unless
you kicked that bear's ass that's true
how would you do that
[ __ ] rip its head right off i'm a
marine man right just jump on its head
like jump on it from behind and choke it
out and then [ __ ]
you know like start going at it with
your bowie knife
yeah i grab the nearest
source of distraction right whether it's
a big rock or just like a little branch
you wave it in its face yeah they love
that [ __ ] yeah yeah and it's like what
the [ __ ] is this what is this is it food
is it does it think does this beast have
a longer arm than before
and before that stupid-ass bear knows it
bam you're on it rock then yeah brought
to that yeah but this is fantasy marine
maybe this is yeah that's right well by
the way a rock to the head on a bear i
think would probably just be like
it's just gonna piss it off dude you
know what i mean like
there's right down the throat it chokes
on the rock oh you stuff it down its
throat like like uh
i don't know i'm not a marine i haven't
been trained in this i would stick a
bone in its mouth like luke skywalker
did to that creature in return of the
jedi you remember when he gets when he
and falls down into the pit in jabba's
lair yeah and then and then
the rancor yeah the rancor oh yeah yeah
he's and the he's got it and so he takes
a bone and sticks it in his mouth and
you know that was pretty that was pretty
cool and then he throws a rock and hits
the thing and the gate comes down on the
rain course
yeah you know what i always really loved
about that scene can i just say this
real real quick like i would always what
i find so
this is why this is why those for that
first trilogy was just so great
it's one of the reasons one of the many
reasons
but like i love that like he kills this
like
this this monster this monstrous scary
[ __ ] creature that like
basically its whole thing is it eats the
people that get thrown into that pit
right and it's scary and it's got a
scary mouth and it looks scary and it
sounds scary and then luke kills it
and and as it's dying it sounds like a
sweet little it's like
and you kind of feel bad for it and then
the the the trainer the guy who the
handler the rancor's handler that's like
fat guy comes waddling in and is crying
yeah
yeah yeah he's crying because he's
[ __ ] the kids at home up but yeah you
know yeah i just i just thought it was
such a good touch like that that's
somebody's sad
yeah but most movies in the 80s they
would not have they would not have
portrayed a creature like it was more
simple than that was like this is a bad
monstrous creature
and the good guy's gonna kill it and
you're not gonna feel bad at all because
it was a bad creature but in this one
you're like no no it's like there was
someone who cared for this creature who
fed this creature who took care of it
and i just think that's brilliant so
good job george lucas oh star wars yeah
good job star wars i think you're gonna
make it yeah star wars the beatles of
movies what um
i
i know you're the host the host of the
podcast so i'm sorry to take um that
responsibility from you for just a
second but can i ask you
what um what armed force would you like
to join
oh i did want to go back to that yes
well i
i i think um
i think i pretty like by default almost
would have probably joined the air force
because my just because my grandfather
was
well at the time it actually wasn't the
air force it was the army air force
because the air force was a part of the
uh the army they weren't their own
branch yet but um
and then so he was in the air force and
then my then my dad of course was a air
force academy graduate and flew
airplanes and so he was in the air force
so i think i probably would have done
that you know yeah it's pretty awesome
yeah i i always it's like
you know and by the way that's the
reason my my grandfather joined the air
force when he was like in his late 20s
because he knew he was going to get
drafted
for world war ii
uh he was a jazz musician he he played
the trumpet and he played the piano he
was in a jazz band that's what he did he
was a jazz musician but he was like i'm
about to get drafted and he's like i
think i'd rather be in the air than on
the ground
so before getting drafted he joined the
air force and became a pilot
which i think is pretty interesting yeah
yeah but and your dad and your dad
fought in vietnam right i mean
and then my dad flew in vietnam yeah
yeah but it's interesting because my my
grandfather also i mean he saw some
you know i think he thought maybe it was
going to be safer in the air and boy was
it not well my grandfather thought it
would be safer in the sea and it wasn't
no it wasn't safe anywhere no no it was
a war well it was a war it was a war
these are these are some but i mean i'm
not kidding when i tell you that my dad
tells stories of my grandfather that
were told to him by my grandpa my
grandfather never got around i never got
around i was i don't know a kid and i
never got these stories but like my dad
was telling me
after almost every single mission my
grandfather would bring his b-52 bomber
back and land it and it would just look
like swiss cheese yeah
just you know what i mean just getting
shot just shot the pieces up in the sky
like barely getting it back yeah my
grandfather was on an aircraft carrier
and he would talk about getting strifed
like on a daily basis strafed straight
sorry on a on a daily basis and then
like in he he would come home and the
boat would be like torn apart he got he
got shot yeah
and like
they were in their early 20s yeah and
when i was in my early 20s i was
navigating traffic down franklin
right you know what i mean and i was
like this is a bitching about traffic i
gotta [ __ ] sit here while the traffic
goes up laurel canyon i'm like i gotta
get home i gotta get my grandfather died
in the war uh in a military training
accident in an airplane i didn't know
that wow i didn't know that either my
dad was four so i never met the man
oh man yeah how about that
should we hug wow yeah
do we hug him you know so my grandfather
you know his hands on his head
my grandmother you know so hello
thanks guys
mountain mike i never met the man never
met the man oh that that is sad that's
that's too bad that's too bad yeah my my
grandma so my gran one story that my dad
told me about my grandfather that i'd
never heard and he told me this last
christmas i think or the last christmas
i was home which sadly was two years ago
because of the pandemic
um can you can you get more specific
about one second
i know i know i know i go into
unnecessary
give me the time yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah what time was it it was about
12 30. um
were you hungry had you eaten i was
still just doing the coffee thing i
think probably but yeah pacific coast
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah my cousin
was there too he was a helicopter pilot
anyway um all these on this anyway he
was he was flying a mission one one time
and he was flying low
um and his co-pilot who was a very close
friend of his
the plane was getting strafed
and at one point um he
looked his he saw his uh uh um his
friend and his co-pilot literally just
get
physically cut in half
cut in half by bullets
he then fell forward on the yoke and
was pushing the plane downward so my
grandfather had to proceed to
fly the plane with one arm
while holding his best friend with the
other arm holding him up so that he
wouldn't
push the plane push the plane down
and landed the plane that way
that's the kind of thing that like i
can't even
wrap your head around that no to tie it
into the episode in some regard because
we have a deer hunter reference in this
episode for those who've never seen the
movie the deer hunter the the sort of
roulette the russian roulette game
they're playing at the end with frank
little eye patches
stolen directly from the movie the deer
hunter yeah
when i saw that film
it rocked me for two for two reasons one
just like uh
maybe i was young enough to be like oh
this a war is like this
a war is
war is bad
but but also
uh in terms of acting
where i think you know you're a kid and
you see superman or the three amigos or
whatever and you don't i don't really
think much of acting and you see the
deer hunter
and you're like oh acting can be that
that's what acting is and that's the
thing that really that's the movie that
changed me in terms of
yeah the performances in that movie are
just if you guys haven't seen the deer
hunter you gotta you gotta it's just
like it's required view it's just like
sunny
it's very similar to sonic yeah yeah but
it it is amazing to think about like
because i've met your dad and i've hung
out with her dad many times and he
couldn't be kinder or sweeter and he it
must be difficult though in some way to
like come back from what he what he had
to experience in vietnam and then just
full not only just fold back into normal
society but then also have to listen to
people complain about the [ __ ] we
complain about that's right
like everybody's experience and pain and
struggles relative forget that but still
like when to go through something like
that and then come back here and hear me
[ __ ] about like i said like the traffic
on laurel canyon i mean he gives a [ __ ]
yeah no i he he did i mean he did
experience that as i recall i mean he he
i don't know was i let's see how old was
he when he came back i can't remember he
must have been 25 or 26 when he came oh
my brother-in-law the same thing i mean
he did two tours in afghanistan flew
apache helicopters and but he couldn't
be kinder or sweeter and he doesn't he
just texted me the other day he's like i
heard about your foot you know like
because i tore some legs
into my foot and yeah he wasn't like man
up or anything yeah he had empathy yeah
which is which isn't which is crazy
considering what he had to go through
yeah i mean i think those guys felt a
lot i mean i know my dad he came back
and he was like
he didn't he was like he didn't know
what was going on in the culture you
know what i mean he didn't know what was
going on going on like music wise or
like
you know and and i think yeah to some
degree everything just kind of felt like
super weird to him like the things that
people concerned themselves with were
were very strange to him like the
beatles
oh you know what was the thing the
beatles oh yeah oh oh you mean you mean
his experience with the beatles he was a
big guy he's got a long hair now i don't
know i was just trying to i was trying
to bring it back around just because you
know it's a comedy podcast yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah we'll cuddle we got
it we'll cut that kind of stuff
[ __ ]
yes you know very much so but uh many
friends and family
the whole thing about
patriotism man that's that's been
adopted by all sorts of extreme groups
that uh it's pretty frustrating it is
frustrating it it
it's frustrating the implication that uh
if you're a liberal
uh and a democrat that you're not as
much of a patriot that's what it feels
like i know that's maybe not we're all
suffering the extremes of this country
just like the extremes on the right
extremely left i think most people
fall somewhere in the middle and are
just like what can we can these guys
just shut up but they they can't they're
that's that's their thing that's the
nature that's that's what it is you know
um speaking of falling somewhere in the
middle um can we talk about that jacket
should we talk about that jacket for a
second it's kind of sort of like a
southwest vibe glenn's wearing a uh
button-up snap snap-up yeah you're gonna
have to go to the video to check it out
yeah we have video now kind of has like
a
yeah um right like a santa fe kind of
yeah like a i like connor from
succession vibe i dig it
from success which one is right oh you
see the the brother the one who wants
one unfair
yeah
the guy who plays tom amazing oh my god
everybody on that show everyone's
amazing but
like i feel like as an actor i see that
guy and i'm like oh man this guy's got
all the pitches fastball slider curve
everything he does yeah everything he's
got the goods he's got the goods yeah i
couldn't agree more he's he's holy cow
and his his style he's so funny
but his style of being funny is like
nothing i've ever seen it i've never
seen an actor do comedy the way he's
doing comedy he's never top-notch
top-notch
uh is there something else you wanted to
ask me about this jacket i've never seen
that before i've never seen you wear
that even i've never seen you dress in
that style
is this a new thing is this something
we're gonna lean into
no no i've actually had this jacket for
a really long time and i haven't worn it
because i i thought it was i felt like
it was too long
um
you know you can't really see how long
but i actually asked charlie when i
first came in i was like hey man do you
think this jacket's too long no it's not
long so why are we talking why are you
talking to me that we haven't started
the podcast yet right so yeah save it
um no but he actually told me that it
wasn't too long and now i feel pretty
good about it you know what's cool it's
reversible look at that oh yeah i like
it that's a ton of fun isn't that funny
a reversible jacket is just yeah it's a
twofer yeah it's great yeah your dad's
getting shot to [ __ ] and you've got a
reversible jacket that's right there we
go yeah i'm online looking i'm
frustrated because i can't find the
right too for jack you're wondering if
your jacket's too long right
[Laughter]
here look we gotta live you know you
gotta be you hey guys this was the first
time we had mark margaret mcpoyle on the
show yes correct yeah yeah one of the
funniest things in the in the episode if
you again for those of you who are going
to go back and watch these with us um
in the there's a moment where um
where nate mooney's character uh uh
where ryan mcpoyle is making out with
margaret mcpoyle and liam is just
sitting there watching
now do yourselves a favor it's very hard
to take your eyes off of what's
happening with ryan and margaret do
yourself a favor next time you watch it
don't watch ryan and margaret at all
just watch jimmy simpson
just watch liam mcpoyle's reaction to uh
to what to that make out session because
it is
so funny it's so joyful right well yeah
he's just he's just like watching with
like a little like smile on his face and
just like he's just like
yeah
yeah
and he's almost kind of laughing a
little bit like because i think he also
probably jimmy probably found it
slightly amusing and he was like well
that works for the character
i think it's interesting that we're we
kind of
after watching the episodes we kind of
all agree when one
is like
good like holds up you know to our
standard now and we have a we have a
baseline for what we want it to be and
it's like it's
[Music]
difficult to
to make any kind of movie or any kind of
television show work because there's no
math to it there's no science equation
of like you simply add this and this and
this and it all adds up you know
and
and that thing that you're looking for
much like when the beatles are looking
for a song there's no like
meter that goes off and says yes this is
a working song this is how you get there
you have to make it up as you go along
and it's it i agree it's very
interesting that we all have some kind
of standard for what that is
glenn you and i later today are talking
about
the season of sunny um in the press on
another podcast and
uh without discussing you and i both
picked the same episode to talk about
yeah i found that interesting and i do
feel like that particular episode which
is the second of the ireland ones yeah i
feel like is one of the best ones we've
done for years but you know who knows
exactly how we get there or why
it's interesting
so yeah we all watch this episode and
say oh there's moments of what we want
the show to be and there's moments of
what we don't want the show to be and we
can kind of learn from that and go to
the next episode but
you can't really learn until the next
year because we're doing them all the
same time you know
i don't know yeah well and also you just
our tastes you know change through the
years i i'm not my sense of humor is not
the same as it was in 2006 sure but i
bet we i bet we i can't know for sure
but i bet we felt
roughly the same back then roughly where
we were probably like oh yeah there's
some good parts of this one and you know
maybe some aspects that yeah as good as
it can yeah you
[Music]
you were a veil
tech tech on a veil well i could maybe
i'll make myself available for you guys
i thought uh usually i thought you
better
we're good we got it
it's funny yeah we got it yeah we've
learned a lot here yeah yeah we got it
we learned a lot about you yeah i think
we've gotten enough out of you today um
guys i just want to say i love america
uh i am very grateful for this country
that we live in i'm actually not even
joking at all i think we're
extraordinarily lucky to be born here
not that other countries aren't great
too but i'm very happy to be an american
and um
i would like to sign off by just saying
rock flag and eagle
i'm with you i believe in america and i
believe in uh where we can get
with america and you know which is that
that's great thing about this country is
that we can keep attempting to improve
it there's a lot i think there's a lot
of people out there frustrated about uh
where the country's at and and worried
and that's fair and we've been through
bumpy roads before and we'll get through
it or we won't and it's all gonna end i
don't know it may end but if you're
looking for your answers in a comedy
podcast you know that's probably part of
what's wrong yeah
yeah yeah rob uh
rob rock flag and eagle suddenly you
said rob flagging eagle
um
yeah that's a that's a freudian slip
there okay yeah rock
flag yeah
an eagle all right well john paul and
ringo
[Music]
[Applause]